six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's try our caller from the eight one
three area code caller from eight one
three go ahead hi sort of it sounds like
we're either on like Bluetooth or
speaker house this is better that is
better thank you okay I just had a hi my
name is Andrew calling from Tampa
Florida brand I just had a oh I'm sorry
that's your safe um uh I had a two
questions first question is have you
been paying attention to the she was it
oh the case I believe it was a week ago
is right around the time the Omarosa
tape scandal happens I put scandal the
quotation which case is that about the
UH the coalition forces in Iraq one of
the spokespersons a colonel I believe I
can't remember his name basically saying
to reporters oh yeah we're we're just
going to be here and until we're we're
done yes we covered around the bony
choice
I'm aware of that story you did cover it
okay
i I'm an Internet listener I don't have
the show yet on anything I only hear
snippets of your show so okay
my other question is have you also been
have you also been aware of what's going
on with Turkey and Kurdistan well Syrian
border typical what's specifically about
it alright listen now your connection is
just cutting out I'm sorry I I'm aware
of the countries and that there is a
conflict your connection is a disaster
right now so I'm gonna have to let you
go